hey you guys movie retrospective time
going back to the 1980s big old frizzy
hair
big old shoulder pads this was 80s yeah
87. yeah
why
i didn't realize it was that old i saw
it when it came out
i think i don't think i saw this in the
theater because i think i was only 15
when this came out but i think i saw it
a year or two later like on cable this
movie fatal attraction was
massive i mean this was like it only
cost like according to wikipedia it only
cost 14 million dollars to make it and
it made 320 million dollars it was the
second highest grossing movie in the u.s
after three men and a baby
uh and yeah
i think i saw that movie i don't really
remember that much about it but um
but it was the number one highest
grossing movie in the world that year i
think i saw in the theater everybody
said
i kind of feel like everybody saw it
like i said i was a little bit young and
i don't think that was something that my
parents would have taken me to see
necessarily because it's like you know
an erotic thriller and i'd have been
like weirded out like going to see with
my parents anyway but um you know
especially like with all the weird sex
scenes but yeah everybody was seeing it
not in you know in 1887 in high school i
think i think yeah we're all talking
about it they liked it i liked it yeah i
liked it on a first viewing and then on
subsequent viewings is once you kind of
know
i don't know once you've seen it it's
it's not as fun like it's it's fun this
when this movie was new it was the only
thing like it
now there's a lot of like well and
that's the thing it's like it's kind of
not necessarily this movie's fault i
mean yeah there had been erotic
thrillers prior to this we're not saying
that but i kind of feel like this movie
was so successful i mean it was this was
nominated for best picture for christ's
sake um you know it didn't win but it
was nominated and adrian lyon the guy
that directed it he was directed he was
uh nominated for best director glenn
close was not made for best actress like
i said it didn't win any but
um it was nominated for a [ __ ] ton so it
was like a cultural phenomenon at the
time and i think that it because it was
so successful it kind of spawned a lot
of these sort of
knockoff like stalker thriller type
movies that kind of came in the wake of
that like you know single white females
i mean i'm not [ __ ] on single wave
female because i actually really do like
that movie
but
you know you had stuff like um what was
that one with [ __ ]
madonna and willem dafoe oh body of
evidence yeah the one with the hot wax i
don't think i sat through that whole
movie because i heard it was awful but i
don't know i don't know it's kind of
like the whole thing now one thing that
is interesting to me and maybe this is
another movie that we need to do because
i remember this movie being really good
there was actually a movie with a very
similar plot to this back in i want to
say the 70s but i can't remember maybe
it was 77 78 was clint eastwood and it
was called play misty for me did you
ever see that never saw it but i
remember he was like a dj and he had
this female fan that became like a star
like obsessed with him and became a
stalker he wasn't married or anything
but um it's it's a horror movie it's
actually really really good i haven't
seen it in a long time and you'd you'd
probably dig it yeah but it's a similar
story to this
so the interesting thing about this
movie like i said it was directed by
adrian lyon who as far as i know i think
he's still alive and i think he's still
working nowadays but he's kind of most
famous for his movies that he did like
in the 80s and 90s like he did flash
dance you know which again was a huge
cultural phenomenon uh nine and a half
weeks you know that really erotic
thriller jacob's ladder he directed
jacob's ladder and he also did indecent
proposal which is that was the one with
woody harrelson and demi moore right
where the guy comes in and says hey i'll
give you a million dollars to sleep with
your wife and they're just kind of like
maybe we should do that but yeah it was
that kind of situation so it's like the
same director so he's kind of known his
wheelhouse a little bit other than
jacob's ladder i guess is kind of more
of these erotic thriller type situations
this is not that erotic though come on
no not really but that's well that's the
genre that they would call it i'm not
saying that i find it particularly
erotic but you know what i mean i'm just
saying that that's the genre in it yeah
it's like glenn close shows her boobs
but yeah but nobody wants to see that
but that's about it well you know what's
interesting is they actually um the
first actress that they wanted for that
role yeah was uh barbara hershey
who uh you know she was in she was in
the entity and she was in a bunch of
stuff in the 80s and she was supposed to
get that role but glenn close really
really wanted it um they didn't want to
give it to her for the same reason
you're saying they're like well she's
not like super sexy yeah um but when she
came in like they she let her hair go
all crazy and like with the black dress
and everything they're like oh okay
because she really wanted this part
really bad and honestly i think that
it worked out in
in the favor but i don't know i kind of
feel like at the time that this came out
i don't really know because i you know
like i said i was only a teenager i kind
of feel like maybe when this movie came
out and
a lot of the you know commentary on it
afterward was kind of like about dudes
like seeing the movie and being like
holy [ __ ] i'll never cheat on my wife
because that was like a horror movie for
like a dude that she's on your wife and
it almost seemed like they wanted you to
feel sorry for michael douglas's
character dan
even though
his dumb ass is
like kind of i'm not saying that alex
forrest the you know glenn closes
character i mean obviously she had some
uh
issues big time but had he just not
[ __ ] her then
none of that would have happened yeah
you know he said the other way around
well yeah i'm not saying that i'm just
saying that you cheat on your husband
then he won't blow your head off
well you know i don't know about that
yeah
yeah but i'm just saying that it's like
he ended up well the thing about it is
that he didn't really
you know both the characters are bad but
like i said i think that's kind of what
makes it a good movie because nobody is
really like a hero or a villain
necessarily and i will say too that even
though the ending that you got with the
theatrical cut which is you know
obviously everybody's i feel like even
people that haven't seen this movie like
know what happens at the end
i kind of feel like um the fact of her
coming in like a [ __ ] slasher villain
and trying to kill
uh dan's wife beth
and then uh you know him drowning her
her popping up again like a slasher
villain and then beth like shooting her
in the heart and killing her um that was
an ending that they reshot later
because that wasn't actually the
original ending and that wasn't the
ending that the director wanted what
adrian lyon originally wanted which
actually was more in line with the theme
of the movie
and i saw the actually if you search um
if you search
fatal attraction
uh alternate ending it's on youtube it's
only about eight eight and a half
minutes long what happens in the
original cut
is that alex actually commits suicide
with the kitchen knife that he touched
when he was over at her thing so she was
trying she kills herself but she's
trying to like frame him for the murder
so the cops come and like take him away
but then his wife like after he gets
arrested um she finds like the tape like
the audio tape that she recorded where
she says she's gonna kill herself and
blah blah so she presumably takes that
to the cops and gets him released so the
thing about it is that see that would
have worked out better i feel like
because
the whole underlying theme of the movie
and why they used madame butterfly like
as a touchstone was that that's what
happens at the end of madame butterfly
like at the end of the opera like this
spurned woman and she ends up committing
suicide so it would have been
thematically relevant but i guess they
showed that to test audiences and they
said no we want the [ __ ] to get come up
in so we want her to get killed
so they re-shot the ending glenn close
wasn't super jazzed about it but she's
like you know whatever you gotta kind of
go go along with what the audience
wanted i guess but
i i can see that i don't you know i both
endings are fine
uh the ending the theatrical ending is
much more like i said like a horror
movie type ending whereas
the original ending was more like a
tragic kind of ending
uh which actually acknowledged that you
know even though she did some really
really psycho [ __ ] um you know she was
obviously very mentally unstable
um but you know like i said either way i
know a lot of people like the original
ending better now that they know about
it but you know that's neither here nor
there
so obviously if you haven't seen this
movie uh you know michael douglas he
plays dan he's married apparently
happily married but i guess not that
happily but uh he's married to this
woman named beth who's played by ann
archer and they have a daughter named
ellen
and a dog and all that kind of [ __ ] so
they live in new york city he's a lawyer
or something and she does she even have
a job who or his wife i think no i guess
not i guess she's like i hope that i
never really thought about it because
it's like i don't know she was like out
of town
so uh so they're thinking about like
moving out to the suburbs or whatever
now the wife
uh she's like oh well i'm gonna go out
and go and take the kid and we're gonna
go visit my parents and go look at this
house that we're thinking about buying
um you know she has not been out of town
for like an hour
before
her husband
like goes and like sleeps with this he
had met her previously like at this work
party because i guess she worked for
he was a lawyer for this publishing
company and she worked for the
publishing company like she was an
editor or something so they had met at a
party and they had a little ooh like
moment
but nothing happened then but then like
she kind of he ends up working with her
over the weekend and they start flirting
and then you know obviously like i said
his wife has been out of town for all of
two hours i think uh and he makes a
woman mad he starts banging well no and
he starts banging the chick well the the
thing that makes me mad
she didn't she doesn't see this scene
the way a guy sees it
okay
he's married to a younger woman she's
real cute she's got a kid you know his
kid
he's working with an older woman all
right who's like a peer all right and
they have a lot in common
she's his age
well she comes on to him pretty hard but
it's effective
she seduces him he's like
well she is out of town and [ __ ] this
is a cool chick and she's not gonna know
and
this is just above the table just
between peers basically
we're gonna hook up and that'll be one
it'll be a one-time thing and you know
she said
she seems to be amazing and [ __ ] and
then she'll go about her her own
professional path
nah turn out a lot of [ __ ] was at act
she was a [ __ ] psycho
he can't get rid of her all right and
she's just super super jealous and the
whole thing was trapped
well the thing about it was that like i
said you know and and i'm not saying
this is going to happen it was going
gonna be free love
between people of the future but see
that never happened that's never how
things were right that's just like
usually like a fantasy there's always
people's emotions involved you don't
know what that person's baggage is
obviously
no
that girl was a [ __ ] psycho that one
was a psycho there are many women just
like that that are not psychos that will
have a one-time thing oh i know that
yeah so i'm not saying that you but you
never know is what i'm saying he made
the mistake he didn't know her that well
yeah i mean he yeah he had literally
just met her like for five seconds
and you know i go up places all the time
all right especially down that biker bar
and have [ __ ] women who are [ __ ]
had it
one to ten they might be sevens or
eights come hit me hard
you gotta say nah there's always
something up and then
a week week or so later you find out
yeah something is up with that chick
don't [ __ ]
women that don't know you will not make
a hit will not hit them that's what i'm
saying and that should be your right you
know i can know you and she hits on you
and it's [ __ ] she's like let's let's
let's go ahead and do this you know what
i mean [ __ ] yeah that should be like
a big
um yeah and the fact that i mean some
dudes would be like don't they damn the
consequences and they'll do it anyway
because it's like don't care got laid
she's out of money but she's got
problems
she's got a she's running from a man she
needs somebody to pay her bills there's
all kinds of [ __ ] she's crazy there's
another or
[ __ ]
reason number one she's a hooker that's
the first reason well i mean that's
probably that's the most common reason
because like i said that's
99.99 of the time she just comes out of
nowhere
a woman that just comes at it and starts
hitting on you like in a bar or
something like that yeah i'm not saying
99.9 percent of the time she's a hooker
a lot of times [ __ ] is a hooker yeah but
you know no she's if she's good looking
she's a hooker yeah or like i said if
she's not desperate if she's not
then she has something else i don't know
because like i said
99.99999 percent of women uh will not do
that to a dude that they don't know
right but in this case in the movie
she's a peer she's in the same business
yeah she's the same age as him she's
being all amazing and intellectual and
[ __ ] so he thinks it's safe it wasn't
she's [ __ ] crazy
yeah well i was i was watching a bunch
of stuff earlier and a lot of psycho and
actually glenn close like to play this
role uh she consulted a lot of
psychologists and psychiatrists and
stuff like that being like well what is
this just so i kind of know what the
parameters of it are and uh most people
will tell you that this what she has in
the movie is borderline personality
disorder
um she's pretty i mean it's uh an
extreme version of it for sure
some kind of per personality but yeah
it's borderline personality
borderline personality and with with a
touch of what they call um erotomania
that's kind of like the the layman's
term for it it's it's not what you think
it is errata mania it doesn't mean
you're a sex addict that's that's
something else erato mania means that
you have delusions that somebody else uh
more powerful or you know you richer or
better looking or whatever is in love
with you yeah so that's another thing
too so that's probably what her problem
is
so so yeah so
so he has sex with this woman and
he thinks that she understands that this
is just a one-time thing hey i'm married
blah blah um but
they have a one-night stand he leaves
he's like yeah i gotta go back and like
live my life or whatever and then but
she calls in the next day and she's real
at first she's like just real uh
persistent you know it's like oh you
know why don't you come and we'll spend
the day together your wife isn't coming
back to later blah blah and he's just
trying to steal him and he just kind of
like he's like okay fine um and then it
ends up like he is [ __ ] her all
weekend and doesn't get any work done so
he has to go to work like really early
and all this other kind of crap now
after that like i said he kind of thinks
that it's going to be oh with kate's
over we can't really see each other
anymore and she seems to understand that
at first but then
obviously uh she starts having like a
little bit of a meltdown and then she
comes and tells him that she's pregnant
and they never do say i guess it's
established that she actually is
pregnant because i couldn't remember it
had been a long time since i watched
this i'm like that did she just say that
like to sort of but
he calls her doctor
and the doctor says congratulations so
i'm assuming that she actually was
pregnant
but they never really like accept like i
don't know if she set it up with the
doctor
hey tell him i'm pregnant you know what
i mean that seems a little crazy but she
did some crazy [ __ ] in this so you know
i don't know but i i thought it was
established that yeah she actually was
pregnant which again that's another dumb
thing that he did is like why didn't he
use a condom this was 1987 aids y'all
you can't just like [ __ ] like i said you
don't know that chick
the fact that he wouldn't even like use
a condom he didn't even ask her if she
was on birth control he didn't do any of
that stuff dumb they were older people
dumb
she was not old
in the movie i don't know how old she
the actress was like but in the movie
she's supposed to be 36. yeah about 40.
and i'm like you can absolutely still
get pregnant when you're 36 yeah but
there was another time that was in back
in the 80s and people in their 40s and
the 80s just didn't weren't like us
teenagers in the 80s they were very
different
i know but still even if you i mean
like i said pregnancy was still a thing
aids was a big was a thing um aids still
was mostly a gay gay thing happening in
the game or that's what most people
perceived it was 80. that's that's yeah
in the 80s well that's who was dying
and and if you look at the numbers today
that's mostly who died
but it's just kind of straight people
but it was mostly the gay people i mean
you would think though that even if it
wasn't for aids even if it wasn't for
pregnancy then you would at least just
to be on the safe side that you at least
want to wrap it up or at least ask her
if she was on birth control i'm just
saying that didn't happen so he wasn't
it was a wild fling he wasn't thinking
it was a wild flank and he wasn't
thinking and it ended up getting the
thing about it is that he
he didn't really end up um
having anything bad happen to him
specifically it almost seemed more like
everything it was like it was kind of
like a blast radius where it kind of
like you know it ended up like his uh
little girl got kidnapped so like the
little girl's bunny got murdered um you
know the wife ends up in a car accident
because she's frantically like looking
for the daughter who's been kidnapped so
it was that kind of stuff it was almost
kind of like
so so it wasn't like he even got i'm not
saying he didn't get punished i'm just
saying that nothing happened to him
specifically it ended up happening to
everyone around him so it was almost
kind of like just this one transgression
i think that's what really resonated
with
guys when they saw this movie and glenn
close says on record saying that she
still has like dudes coming up to her
like even nowadays like dudes that
didn't see it back in the day and saying
uh you know thank you so much for making
that movie you like you saved my
marriage like i was because i was gonna
go cheat and then i saw that movie and i
was like okay maybe not um so i get that
so it's like a horror story like that
but i think that's what resonated so
much is that you [ __ ] up one time
and it just blows your whole entire life
up pretty much and doesn't only put you
at risk but puts your whole entire
family at risk just shows you how
vulnerable you are if a person wants to
[ __ ] you over they can you can run into
a crazy person and they could [ __ ] your
life over yeah and like i said it
because he didn't know her
um you know he'd only met her like a
couple of times in those you know just
at a party situation and then like he
just talked to her for a few minutes
like over coffee or something you don't
know what's going to happen
if you get like
involved with that person and then
you'll be like yeah i don't really want
to be involved with you you never know
how that person's going to react you
know what i mean so she carried herself
well
yeah so that's what i'm saying so it's
like you can't really i'm not saying
don't trust anybody ever but i'm just
saying that
this is a this is a reason and i'm not
saying you know hey if you're single
like go out and do whatever the hell you
want i don't care but i'm just saying
that it's sometimes better to like have
a little bit of circumspection about you
know how much do i know about this
person do i really want to get involved
with this person are they going to like
end up this movie is the worst case
scenario it is yeah but like i said if
i'm single most of my damn life all
right
most of the time when you run into a nut
within about 15-20 minutes you know
you're dealing with a nut yeah usually
not always though not always very rare
could you have a nut of this caliber you
know what i mean she's get she makes
money she's got a decent background she
can talk she's real charming usually
they're not like that
usually a nut is running on a facade a
very thin facade
and uh if you're real observant like me
because i'd i could figure people out
pretty quickly just just body language
what people are wearing i know what's up
the thing about her though is she comes
across as very successful very sane well
she was successful yeah she had like a
big job and she had money i mean she had
a nice apartment but here's the thing
usually a nut can't be successful
there's a lot of other products but like
i said not only they can't be successful
usually
um
and to be honest i kind of feel like
let's say for for the sake of argument
that he had this affair with her and
then he decided oh i like her better
than my wife and he decides to divorce
his wife and go with her would that
woman of like would glenn close's
character flipped out i think she didn't
really yeah she'd have flipped out
anyway i mean she would have eventually
but i think that it was engendered
mostly by him rejecting her
and her feeling like
that he just kind of like you know
banged her and left which she kind of
did and the thing about it is that the
[ __ ] that see she like i said i'm
absolutely not saying that she uh wasn't
a psycho because she was but i'm saying
that a lot of the stuff that she said to
him
at first
was true
but it's just you know it didn't justify
surprising things she it didn't justify
like you know she basically said he
didn't really care but he just cared
about having a good time he didn't
really care what he was offering right i
know that but he didn't really care
about
what the repercussions of it were going
to be that's what she meant so i was
like yeah but she said neither did she
basically so see this is well no like
i'm saying they're both they're both
shitty characters i'm not saying that
they're both shitty people they're both
shady people her not him he was he was
he was a good dude she just he just fell
prey
to a [ __ ] um to to a predatory woman
he did
he did she [ __ ] she held out the
promise of a good time
and then it was that she was
sophisticated it would just be this
[ __ ] little flag and you'd never see
her again that's what she promised
that's not what happened
she's [ __ ] crazy she broke the deal
well like i started to do
she was a nut
yeah
but he shouldn't have done it
he's a lot of [ __ ] people shouldn't do
it doesn't doesn't mean that they had to
know no i'm just finished like that he
should i mean yeah but that's well
that's kind of the point of the movie
though the gravity that's kind of the
point of the movie though is that you
never know right i mean you never know
if you're you know what's crazy about
this and see here's the thing there's
always this kind of thing in women what
you cheated so therefore it was okay
that she killed you no no no i didn't
say that i didn't say that i didn't say
that either she tried to kill him she
tried to kill the wife well now i will
note that he tried to kill her first
yeah but she was [ __ ] threatening the
whole family she killed the [ __ ] body
rabbit she was [ __ ] threatened yeah
yeah i know that but the thing about it
dangerous i but the thing about it he
says i'll [ __ ] kill you if you don't
leave
was that he did [ __ ] to her too
and in some ways like and then she would
retaliate but like and escalate it yeah
she was she was totally unjustified
though in everything she did yeah but
yeah i'm not saying that she should
psycho yeah i know but i'm not saying
that she should have done any of that
i'm just saying you know she should have
just like taken off and everybody would
have been just like happier for it
nobody ever would have found out
anything it had been fine but i'm just
saying that he like he did some [ __ ] to
her first and like i said he actually uh
you know tried to kill her first and you
know and then she came back like worse
and like retaliated so that was that
kind of thing and yeah that's what i'm
saying i'm saying he handled it wrong
honestly
um and because before she did anything
um that was legally because he couldn't
really prove a lot of the early [ __ ]
that she did you know what i mean yeah
like yeah she threw acid on his car it's
like we know she did that but they can't
prove it he's kind of and you go so so
he goes to the cops and the cops
basically says look we can't do anything
you made your bed you got to lie in it
and he's and he's a lawyer he should
have known that all right well yeah but
the funniest scene to be is he goes to
the cops at first and pretends that he's
talking about a friend or like a client
of his it's like a friend not me um did
this and then like trying to get advice
and i thought that was like super funny
but then like later he kind of like
dropped that charade but yeah i mean the
cop had a point he's like look you know
yeah baby she did these things but you
can't prove it and until you have
something we can prove then we can't do
anything what he should have done
was that when the second that she well
one he had the tape that she'd made
um and he should have given that to the
cops
number one i don't know why he didn't he
didn't because they would that would
have been evidence in a court and a wife
would have found out well yeah and that
see that's the problem another thing too
is that he should have told the wife
like right away and then that would have
taken a lot of the air out of the sales
of the whole thing because because then
he wouldn't have had the continued like
thing to he could to have his wife not
find out like i think that like made it
escalate he was in new york though and
he had money okay what he could have
done is gone to some dirty pis
and hadn't put them on her case and they
could have busted her up so badly that
she wouldn't be able to work and she'd
have been driven out of business and
would had to have moved and left new
york that's what i would have done to
her
burn her car up just break her leg but i
mean the thing about it it's like i mean
yeah if you want to go like the extra
legal route i mean where you're gonna
get in trouble but i'm just saying that
he had legal recourse after particularly
after she
took the daughter i mean she didn't hurt
the daughter but that's still kidnapping
and
all you had to do and i was watching
another video about that it's like all
he would have had to do was go to the
daughter and bring the daughter to the
police and show him a picture hey is
this the lady that took you there you go
you can go arrest her and she would have
been in jail yeah and and none of that
like the ending [ __ ] would have happened
he was trying to and his way and the
wife already knew at that point yeah he
told the wife after
after she killed the bunny yeah he told
the wife after she killed the bunny yeah
so and before the kidnapping so he could
have got her like for the kidnap because
that is absolutely made a good movie
though no i'm just saying that in real
life
um you know it he should have handled it
much differently than he handled it
uh you know and once there became
actions that you know like that were
actionable like i said kidnapping
because yeah she killed the bunny we
know she did that but you couldn't prove
it yeah unless you have in real life
what happens is that the woman tries to
steal the man okay when she fails the
woman then contacts the [ __ ] wife of
the man and says i [ __ ] a rat on him
this and that he loves me you need to
leave him and that well that's usually
what they do we'll see but that's that's
what i was saying before about how
michael douglas's character yeah dan his
name's dan for christ's sake that's much
easier to say than michael douglas's
character i don't know why i keep doing
that but
that's initially why he started beating
the [ __ ] out of her and like i said he
did that first because she didn't do
anything to him she just said i'm gonna
tell your wife and then he starts
beating on her like no you're not a
[ __ ] so like i said had he just
told his wife at the beginning hey i
[ __ ] around he beat him he beat her or
he roughed her up
well kind of the same thing like he
pushed her against the wall and he
threatened to kill her yeah that's not
beating somebody up beating somebody
totally up now later on
later on
without a difference i mean the law is
still going to see it as no you know in
a various way one would be one would be
simple battery that's what i'm saying
but it's still but it's still illegal
it's just like a difference it's a great
simple battery later on he actually
tried to strangle her and was gonna kill
her but then he decided not to that's
still simple battery and you know that's
the scene too because i always kind of
wondered about that because i didn't
know there was an alternate ending but
that was the scene where he almost
strangled her right and then like he's
like oh i better not because you're
already in hot enough water as it is but
then like he took the knife from her
and his like uh fingerprints were on it
and he very like deliberately like puts
it down on the counter and then like
backs away and like leaves and she's
like against the wall like looking at it
the reason that that scene is in there
is because that was the knife that she
later used to slash her own throat like
to essentially frame him for murder
because it had his fingerprints on it
because he had been there and he had
touched it so that was like why they put
that scene in there and then why it
wasn't like
referenced again because the movie
originally had a different ending uh and
it would have made more sense but what i
was going to say too is like when she
kills the bunny rabbit and like i said i
absolutely don't condone because like
you kill an animal as far as i know
that's
i don't know why they deserve to get why
were they leaving that bunny outside
anyway
well i don't yeah i don't know
most people that have rabbits keep them
indoors from well if it's a pet rabbit
yeah and it's just kind of like i feel
like yeah if i wouldn't put it outside
especially out in like kind of a
suburban or rural area because like you
have dogs and foxes and other kind of
[ __ ] coming like eating and keep a bunny
outside yeah if that's a pet bunny he
knows it was food bunny that's what i'm
saying so yeah the one they shouldn't
have got i mean probably but the thing
about it is that even if you kept the
bunny inside i mean she obviously came
inside and boiled the rabbit so even if
the rabbit was inside she still would
have got it anyway so i think it's
interesting that from this movie came
the phrase which is still in use today
bunny boiler
um you know and that's referring to her
character in this movie but you know
what i think is interesting is that
bunny boiler usually that always refers
to a woman right a woman that does this
kind of stuff
even though
in stalking in stalking type situations
like kind of like what this is 75
percent of the time
75 of the time the stalker's a man so
but if there's no male equi equivalent
of bunny boiler yeah well it's just a
fictional thing that came out of a movie
yeah i know but it's just like i think
that's kind of interesting that we don't
have a male phrase but even though it's
a lot more common like for males to
to do this kind of like behavior
especially after they get rejected like
you know just uh statistically i don't
know i just thought that was like kind
of weird but yeah i mean the poor rabbit
uh i was watching this other review too
like later where
the guy said the only the only person i
feel sorry for in this movie is the
rabbit
i mean you kind of feel sorry for the
wife you feel sorry for the kid because
the wife didn't do anything wrong all
she did was like go and visit and the
thing about it too
had they wanted here's another thing
had they wanted to make dan's character
more sympathetic because he
he's a little bit sympathetic but he
didn't seem that sympathetic to me um he
just got sucked into some [ __ ] i think
if they'd wanted to make him more
sympathetic what they could have done
from a writing standpoint is instead of
making his wife like this delightful and
ha and him being like happily married
and having a happily happy kid and all
this other kind of stuff and like a nice
life
they could have made it so like him and
his wife were kind of like fighting a
lot or something like that that would
give you more of a reason
that he would because i think one of the
problems that i have and why i don't
find him that sympathetic is because i
didn't really see enough of a reason
that he would blow up his life
just to like like like i said like five
minutes after his wife leaves town like
to
to hump this woman that he doesn't
really know i'm like she was gone i know
but yeah but that's but see that's just
that's sexist against men too because it
basically says oh men are just the worst
you can't leave them alone for a second
and they'll just go like pump anything
that moves no what i'm saying is that
had they established early on that like
him and his wife oh maybe like they were
gonna separate or some [ __ ] like that
like there was something going on then
you would kind of like understand well
you know it's not right what he did but
it's more understandable like to me it
just seemed like i was like dude you
have like a really nice wife she seemed
like they y'all weren't fighting you had
a nice family you got a nice house you
got money like why would you want to
like [ __ ] it all up the movie's just
being honest you know what i mean the
average guys are gonna be [ __ ]
tempted by some [ __ ] like that this is
like some amazing woman that has a lot
in common with him and the the wife
isn't around and she's promising some
free sex it'll be all cool [ __ ]
knowing whatever ain't nothing free
[ __ ]
he's like
yeah okay why not take a vacation from
the wife you know what i mean and then
it turns out [ __ ] no
she tries to steal him away from the
wife see
basically what she tries to do and then
it's all the whole situation gets [ __ ]
up then and nothing too and i told you
this like at the end of the movie i was
just kind of like if i was the wife beth
the ant archer character i'm like after
all that [ __ ] that he put me through no
way would i take you take your ass back
oh it's all for forgiven [ __ ] that no
[ __ ] way
i was like you almost got a [ __ ] job
you almost got me killed you almost you
got her kid kidnapped you got the bunny
killed yeah i think he's just happy to
have her family back i guess but it's
like i don't know i don't think i'd be
as forgiving as her but she she just
seemed like i was like man that is one
saintly ass woman that would put up with
that crap like after all of that but i
think she just saw that other chick
realized how [ __ ] crazy she was and
she was just like oh yeah well you know
[ __ ] he learned his lesson
he won't do that again
maybe that's why she's like well maybe
now he's trained yeah but
it's like after he had that experience
i'm just yeah i'm just saying that it's
i like this movie i really do i think
it's i think it's a good movie um you
know i think it's still kind of and it's
funny because i was watching some other
like reviews of it by people that were
like not even born when it came out and
a lot of them really liked it i saw this
one like canadian guy who actually was
uh was a film major
and he was talking about all kind of
like the way uh the shots changed like
over the course of the film like as the
tension like escalated and stuff and he
and he like really really dug it yeah
well crafted movie it is it is very good
and adrian lyon um like i said i've i've
liked a lot of his films i haven't seen
any of his uh newer ones but you know i
kind of have a soft spot for flash dance
and uh and i love jacob it's a good
movie
um if you haven't seen it go check it
out but in my opinion there's another
movie that is kind of like this that i
like a lot better called cape fear
yeah it's a stalker movie but it doesn't
have anything to do with adultery no
it's more like oh that he's like he's
getting back at the lawyer's family like
that put him on dude gets out of prison
and [ __ ] he takes revenge on his
lawyer who [ __ ] didn't didn't
evidently
didn't
now where are we talking about the
robert de niro one or three are the
original
one they're both good i mean they're
both good and robert de niro and i
thought was really good just because
that the way robert de niro pulled that
character off he's an ex-con who comes
out and he wants revenge on his lawyer
because his lawyer
didn't give him an adequate defense and
it looked i guess it was on purpose that
he didn't give him an adequate defense
and he's like he was guilty and he never
even said he was innocent he was guilty
which like i said to me that seems like
crazy is like uh you know yeah i was
guilty and i went to prison but she
didn't defend but you didn't defend me
is good enough so i'm gonna come out and
like show you that i'm an absolute like
who absolutely should be a president
he could have gotten off yeah
he had some piece of evidence i forgot
exactly what it was the lawyer had a
certain his defense attorney had a piece
of evidence yeah that's right that would
have gotten him off
but he hid that piece of evidence
from everybody to make sure that he went
down even though he was defending him
he's a rapist
yeah but he had a piece of but see the
thing about that though is that he if i
mean and i can see the lawyers like it's
not ethical for sure like hiding
evidence but if you know that he's
guilty
you're kind of like well i could let him
get off and then he might go out and
like rape and maybe murder other people
no he did kind of the war thing that's
what i'm saying and it's like yeah it's
not legal or really ethical from the
career standpoint but it's like it's
probably morally the right thing to do
right well that was the good that was
the thing it was it's kind of critical
of the of the criminal justice system
and legal systems there's problems in
them
well yeah both sides you know well like
i said you kind of see that too i mean i
you see that a little bit because i
guess this you know uh fatal attraction
doesn't have like a lot of the cop stuff
but i do kind of feel like he does go to
the cops at one point before she's
really done anything like i said
actionable yeah we know she's done some
[ __ ] yeah she poured aston out of his
car yeah she killed the rabbit yeah she
did that but they couldn't prove it so
at that point like you know the cops so
in a way they were kind of talking a
little bit about particularly in stalker
situations a lot of times stalkers know
exactly what they they can get away with
um without getting in trouble with the
police you know what i'm saying and i
think that was kind of the situation
here although she didn't really seem to
care all that much yeah but it's the
same thing with cape fear with the one
with they were he was doing that a lot
he he knew how to get around the law so
nothing could happen to him
when he was in prison he became
basically
learned everything about the law he he
could he was equivalent to a lawyer and
he was uh and he knew everything about
police investigative
techniques everything it's a good movie
good movie it's different than this one
though it's it's man on man well i was
going to say this is like
a stalker movie it is but yeah it's not
really the same
vibe or anything like that although i
absolutely think that we should do cape
fear because i really really do like
that movie honestly
you know what would be good is if we
could watch both of them but like both
versions and like do a do a thing on
that but like i said i think the most
similar to this one that i've seen and
that i can think of is probably play
misty for me the clint eastwood movie
from the 70s um it's very very similar
like i said it doesn't have the adultery
aspect because as far as i remember like
clint eastwood's character and that was
just a single guy um and he has like an
obsessed fan that he actually does hook
up with but then like she turns out to
be a psycho later on so it doesn't have
like i said it doesn't have the whole
like adultery aspect to it so you so
again like you're a lot more sympathetic
in that movie you're a lot more
sympathetic to clint eastwood's
character like the male character
because he wasn't you know he wasn't
[ __ ] anyone else over he was a single
guy he's like hey she's a single girl
and they had a thing and then it wasn't
really his fault that she flipped that
she flipped out on him and was a stalker
and was crazy and he didn't know that um
i kind of feel like in this movie he's
less sympathetic
because he had a nice family and a nice
life who was he was going to be hurting
by doing this and he would have been a
good if he was single though just
wouldn't no i know it would have been
yeah it would have been a different
movie because he he i'm not saying i
wasn't i'm not saying talking about the
quality of the movie i'm just saying
that he would have been a more
sympathetic character him being married
him being married with a wife and kid
with a young good-looking wife and
raised the stakes for him yeah he had a
lot more to lose yeah well yeah that's
what makes this more a horror movie
than
you know because so i i i agree with the
movie the way the movie went and i agree
with the way they did the character and
he he was
morally ambiguous yeah i mean
that's what makes the movie good that's
what i'm saying and that's what i liked
about it i'm just saying that
yeah i liked that like neither one of
them were really all that great people i
mean obviously she was like really
crazier than him but it's like you know
he obviously uh [ __ ] up a lot you know
yeah
so yeah i'm just not saying that i'm
just saying that it seemed to me like
the movie and i don't know maybe maybe
i'm reading into it but it seemed to me
like the movie wanted him to be more
sympathetic than i found him
that's all i'm saying and i was like if
you wanted to make him sympathetic i
don't think that would be good for the
movie because i think the movie is good
the way it was but if you wanted to make
him more sympathetic there would have
been ways to do it it was late late 80s
boomer generation was really who it was
targeted at yeah they cheated on each
other they just did that's just the way
it was it was they were trying to like
scare them straight i don't think so i
don't think so they just took the [ __ ]
yeah that's how it is
[ __ ] you know growing up in brazil i
mean [ __ ] every
if you were a married man and [ __ ]
you had a wife and kid and a good career
and you had a mistress too it was just
part of the culture
the wives knew
which yeah but see that's that's the
kicker though is that i don't i don't
have a problem with it as long as the
wives know about it yeah well the wives
usually don't know the mistress they
just assume no i'm just i'm just saying
that it's like it's quite different like
i said i don't think i don't have a
problem with it as you know as a rule
i'm just saying that it's it's all about
like expectations yeah like if you know
that your husband is running around on
you and you're fine with it he's not
right and you're and you're allowed to
get a personal secretary but you know
what i mean like i'm just saying like if
everybody knows about it yeah then it's
fine yeah
the problem evolved like the problem
arises like when one person thinks oh
this person is uh you know
is monogamous and they're not monogamous
and they're trying to keep it from you
right so i think it's more like the you
know the the american way is to [ __ ]
lie and to cheat that's what i'm saying
and that's what i have the problem with
that it's not it's not so much the the
[ __ ] around it's the lying about it
that that's the problem well the latins
lied to oh baby you know there's nothing
going on but the [ __ ] they they know
but it's just that's just in the culture
uh but the thing is is that a lot of
times the wives don't care because that
means they got another woman to help
them to pick up the slack they're sick
of [ __ ] that dude you know what i
mean
but see the thing about this movie
though is that obviously the wife had
the expectation yeah right that he was
not [ __ ] around like that he was like
there with a family so you know what i
mean because she was
mad when she found i mean you know
understandably uh and justifiably so but
i'm just saying that yeah that that's a
whole different kettle of worms like
when you're talking about kettle of fish
can of worms whatever
i said kettle of forms yeah same type
but uh yeah so that's kind of where it
arises it's more like lying about it
than the actual thing if everybody knows
what everybody's up to
then it's then you can't really say
anything yeah but i think it's just like
they just know how it goes or but yeah
but like i said if you're like lying to
other people's face and like you know
and trying like not to get caught and
[ __ ] like that which which dan
absolutely was in this movie like he he
threatened to kill
uh alex when she said i'm gonna call
your wife and tell her that i [ __ ] you
yeah so
he obviously didn't want his wife to
find out because he knew that it would
that she would be mad and that it would
ruin his life and that she might take
his kid away you know what i'm saying
which probably would have happened
evidently the chinese are just like that
too all the married guys have mistresses
that's us but you know it's not just
it's not just [ __ ] american culture
and south american culture well it's
like these places they say they say that
china is like that big time china japan
i've heard i've heard that france is a
lot like that too but i don't but i
don't really know i was having never
been there myself yeah and only having
known one or so just a big [ __ ]
everybody's just [ __ ] everybody
that's what i mean but like i said i
don't have a problem with that at all as
long as everybody knows what's going on
it's kind of floating i just don't like
i just charts yeah i just don't like
people being left in the dark or maybe
having or maybe telling or maybe you
know telling your significant other oh
i'm totally faithful to you and then
like [ __ ] everything that moves it's
like then i have a problem with that but
it's like if everybody knows then it's
fine in brazil though [ __ ] the
cultural expectations was that you have
to defend your wife's honor to her face
so you supposed to lie to her but the
wife knows that you're alive that's it's
that's that kind of deal it's very
complex
because catholicism involved in honor
cultures and [ __ ] yeah i get it so
you're not getting it so
but it's it's superficial everything's
kind of but but it emotion emotionally
driven but superficial on
well i kind of yeah well i feel like
everything like those kind of cultures
it's usually like a lot about
appearances the appearances like you can
kind of do like all kind of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] like under the radar as long as
like everything looks all respectable
yeah you know what i mean like that
because yeah i kind of feel like the
south used to be like that yeah not so
much anymore but yeah it depends on
where you go well in particular well i
i'm talking about about like real
religious areas yeah like yeah like
people would be like
just just all kind of [ __ ] up [ __ ] but
as long as she uses yeah you don't want
everybody knowing you're doing the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] but everyone's doing the
phone right yeah the [ __ ]
you just don't want it to be the
southern baptist the southern baptist
minister is the one getting all the
action in the whole town right seven
eight girlfriends everybody knows but
it's like it's not it's gauche to talk
about it
[Laughter]
because he's the local celebrity you
know right basically so it's like that
yeah uh but yeah so where do we watch uh
we watch fatal attraction it's on hbo
max at the moment uh i think it might
also be on amazon prime not entirely
sure but that's where we watched it and
i was actually like quite happy because
i saw this like a million times like on
cable back in the late 80s and early 90s
and i think it held up like pretty well
um you know but since it came out there
have been a lot of other movies like
this
so it might not be i don't know it might
not be as like iconic as it was because
like if like i said it was a massive
cultural phenomenon when it came out
like back in the 80s it's kind of like
the og kind of like like i said yeah
play misty for me was kind of like this
too but it's not exactly the same
because it doesn't have the 80s yuppie
adultery angle to it this one's real
well crafted too it is it's a nice
looking movie like the way the shots are
composed
looks nice yeah i mean like i said glenn
close has like super [ __ ] 80s hair
and big shoulder pads and stuff but that
was just kind of like part for the
course back then yeah it's it's uh it's
vintage
it's been taking you back to it's true
because that's when it was it was 1987
but yeah so i'm sure probably most
people have seen this or at least
no um because it kind of really
penetrated the cultural zeitgeist i
guess so it's like i feel like most
people even if you haven't seen it
you've still kind of seen it but uh yeah
tell us what you think about it in the
comments and that'll do it for this
movie retrospective we will see you guys
on the next one
bye